a I believe on our show from Courage
when you came into the studio you talked
about Orson Welles briefly and you
talked about how he mentioned this 90/10
rule verdict about filmmaking and that
90% of it is hustling and 10% of it is
creativity
you know and in following Orson Welles
story recently I've become very
intrigued with him what do you think it
was that was his sort of downfall a
cipher maybe addiction or something I
mean he he was basically handed the keys
or at our young age he was sort of a
child prodigy and things didn't turn out
as you would think that they would in
him for me yeah no Orson Welles this
story is a is a really interesting one
it's funny because I think I remember in
a spike Lee interview where they asked
him why he was so into being a
businessman and why at the finding at
the time he had a store and all these
things and he was making commercial and
he said something about he never wanted
to wind up selling wine as an old man
which is what Will's ended up doing
basically you know kind of Schilling may
be selling wine as a cat as a
personality and a commercial as opposed
to making all the films that he should
have been allowed to me in fact I think
Welles is quote about 90% hustlin and
10% creativity and filmmaking as
promised but I think he actually
probably even said it was less per I
said it was 95% hustling but I yeah I
think it's interesting I think that
people resented him from the beginning
because he did he was given this this
sort of creative autonomy that nobody
got ever I mean he came into town as a
radio celebrity and was given by RKO you
know carte blanche like make anything
you want as long as it's this budget
star in it write it however you want
we're gonna give you any notes just make
it and you've got all these directors
who had been in town you know have been
making film since the silence for 25
years and they're like who's this little
kid who gets 20-something kid that
gets all the call the creative control
in the world and I still have to like
listen to studio notes and I've made 50
movies and you know and I've got a like
recut my movie / you know Louie be mayor
or whatever and so I think people
resented him and it's like anything and
they when when you resent somebody like
that he has power like you like you we
want him to fail I also think a part of
it has to do with the fact that Citizen
Kane was such a monumental achievement
the first time out of gate that it was
impossible for him to match that level
of that power that came out of out of
Citizen Kane even though his subsequent
movies are all fantastic in and of
themselves it's it's like you make the
you make the towering achievement and
then it's all downhill from there I
think he always he always said that you
know it's very difficult to make your
best work first because how do you how
do you how do you follow that but I
think that people unfairly said that he
was some of you who went over budget and
over schedule because actually if you
look at the documentation he was
actually very frugal and very wasn't
this crazy you know out-of-control
genius which makes the story even more
tragic you know one of the things that
always upset me was that when he was
older and still trying to get financing
that you know people like Spielberg
would spend you know million dollars on
the Rosebud sled you know had to buy as
a personal memento I came around which
was there's a lot of money but he
wouldn't help him get a movie made so
they admired him and yet they weren't
able to exactly to produce Orson Welles
as well had maybe this last movie and he
wasn't like he was asking for zillions
of dollars he remains this tragic figure
and and infinitely interesting because
he was such a brilliant filmmaker
because he had such a command of the
medium I mean they're very few
filmmakers where you feel that they have
a complete command over the medium
there's some directors that are actors
directors of some directors that are
visual directors the son directors that
have no idea how to edit or use sound
and this was clearly a man who
intuitively had this way with film and
all in all its various aspects so that's
why they're so alive although even the
ones that have failed are interesting
because there's always something going
on
without failure do you think that's a
very common thread the people
self-sabotage because they do get set up
or there is resentment and they they
almost feel guilty maybe it's funny when
you look at people who it's interesting
to look at the films the second films of
people that have made monster hits like
I've always looked at like for example
William Friedkin who like you know had
the success of the French Connection and
the Exorcist and then was basically
given again like carte blanche like okay
you're you're made these monster
commercial critical hits make whatever
you want I don't care how much it costs
and he makes a movie called sorcerer
which is this remake of this of the
great Enric luzo film wages of fear
about about desperate men driving
nitroglycerin through a jungle with Rory
Schneider two Studios made they took two
studios to finance sorcerer no me knows
that movie known and that's like a
gigantic movie and it's actually a very
very good movie but you get the feeling
like why are you calling it sorcerer I
mean the word sorcerer makes it sound
like it's about wizards and stuff and it
had very Scheider at the top of his
popularity it's a big action-adventure
picture with incredible set pieces and
suspense and nobody gave a nobody
saw that movie is like killed it and the
same thing happened obviously with
Michael Jimmy no you know it makes deer
hunter and then you follow it with this
may be the biggest disaster of all time
Heaven's Gate you know so there maybe is
something I think probably maybe there
maybe there's a degree of self sabotage
or guilt but there's also this kind of
like okay now I'm gonna like now that I
have the power I'm going to make the
thing I always wanted and maybe that
thing isn't necessarily the most
commercial thing which is how Hollywood
measures success so I'm grateful for
movies like sorcerer and Heaven's Gate
because you get to see something
realized that wouldn't would never have
been realized had these directors not
made these super popular movies but
oddly enough these are like these are
like the things that kills sometimes
careers so I don't know I haven't been I
haven't been in the situation yet where
I was made something that I was so
successful that I just
to destroy my own career with the next
bill you know maybe hopefully I get
there then I can do that yeah
you